>>> WELL, THERE IS A GRIM NEW
MILESTONE TO REPORT TONIGHT.
ACCORDING TO DATA FROM JOHNS
HOPKINS UNIVERSITY, MORE THAN
800,000 PEOPLE IN THE UNITED
STATES HAVE DIED OF COVID SINCE
THE START OF THE PANDEMIC.
ALSO TONIGHT, NEW CDC DATA SHOWS
THE OMICRON VARIANT IS MORE
TRANSMISSIBLE THAN THE DELTA
VARIANT AND IS BEING DETECTED AT
A RATE OF ABOUT 3% AROUND THE
COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
HERE IN NEW YORK, CORNELL
UNIVERSITY SHUT DOWN ITS CAMPUS
AFTER MORE THAN 900 COVID CASES
AMONG STUDENTS THIS WEEK.
ACCORDING TO UNIVERSITY
OFFICIALS, A QUOTE VERY HIGH
PERCENTAGE OF THOSE CASES ARE
OMICRON VARIANT CASES IN
FULLY-VACCINATED INDIVIDUALS.
THERE IS GOOD NEWS ABOUT
PFIZER'S ANTIVIRAL COVID-19
PILL.
ACCORDING TO THE COMPANY'S FINAL
ANALYSIS, THEY SAY IT IS NEARLY
90% EFFECTIVE IN PREVENTING
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND DEATHS IN
HIGH-RISK PATIENTS.
JOINING US NOW TO TALK ABOUT IT
ALL, MICHAEL OSTERHOLM, DIRECTOR
FOR THE CENTER FOR INFECTIOUS
DISEASE RESEARCH AND POLICY AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF MINNESOTA AND
A FORM MEMBER OF THE BIDEN
TRANSITION TEAM COVID ADVISORY
BOARD.
PROFESSOR OSTERHOLM, APPRECIATE
YOU BEING WITH US.
SO, THIS OUTBREAK AT CORNELL,
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
I MEAN, 900 NEW INFECTIONS.
UNIVERSITY SHUT DOWN.
I MEAN, MORE, IF NOT ALL,
FULLY-VACCINATED INDIVIDUALS.
WHAT DOES THAT SAY?
>> WELL FRANKLY, IT'S A
HARBINGER OF THINGS TO COME.
THIS IS A HIGHLY INFECTIOUS
VIRUS.
AS WE SEE IT MOVE AROUND THE
WORLD AND BECOME ESTABLISHED
EVEN AT A FEW PERCENT, WE ARE
STARTING TO SEE MORE AND MORE
REALLY LARGE OUTBREAKS
DEVELOPING AND SO I THINK WE ARE
WATCHING A WAR RIGHT NOW BETWEEN
THE DELTA VARIANT AND THE
OMICRON VARIANT AS TO WHO'S
GOING TO BECOME THE KING OF THE
VIRAL HILL.
AND I THINK RIGHT NOW, OMICRON'S
TRANSMISSION POTENTIAL MEANS
THAT IT PROBABLY WILL WIN.
>> SO, YOU KNOW, PROFESSIONAL
SPORTS LEAGUES ARE HIGHLY
VACCINATED, HIGHLY TESTED.
THE NFL, THE NHL, ARE SEEING
RISES IN INFECTIONS.
A LEAGUE SOURCE TELLING CNN THAT
28 PLAYERS TESTED POSITIVE TODAY
AFTER 37 DID YESTERDAY.
I MEAN, WHAT DOES A RISE IN
CASES AMONG PRO-ATHLETES TELL
YOU ABOUT WHAT MIGHT BE GOING ON
IN THE GENERAL POPULATION AND
PEOPLE WHO AREN'T REGULARLY
BEING TESTED?
>> WELL, YOU HAVE TO REALIZE,
AGAIN, WE HAVE A DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
VACCINATED.
THOSE UNVACCINATED, OF COURSE,
WHICH WE REALIZE CONTINUE TO
DRIVE A LARGE PART OF THE
SERIOUS ILLNESS.
WITH THE DELTA SITUATION.
BUT WE ARE ALSO BEGINNING TO SEE
MORE AND MORE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
NOT BEEN BOOSTED, MEANING THAT
THEY ARE SIX OR MORE MONTHS OUT
FROM THEIR ORIGINAL FIRST-TWO
DOSES OF THE mRNA VACCINES.
RIGHT NOW, ONLY ABOUT 30% OF THE
COUNTRY HAS ACTUALLY BEEN
BOOSTED OF THOSE THAT COULD BE.
MANY OF THE ATHLETES WE ARE
SEEING RIGHT NOW ARE ACTUALLY IN
THAT CATEGORY AND THAT'S WHY, AS
YOU HEARD YESTERDAY, THE NFL, IN
FACT, PUT IN PLACE MANDATORY
VACCINATION FOR TEAMS -- NOT THE
PLAYERS -- BUT EVERYONE ELSE ON
THE TEAMS BECAUSE OF THAT VERY
ISSUE.
SO, THIS IS WHY WE HAVE TALKED
OVER AND OVER AGAIN ABOUT WHY
BOOSTERS ARE SO IMPORTANT.
THAT'S WHAT IS GOING TO CONTINUE
THIS DRIVE THIS SITUATION.
>> SO WHAT DO YOU EXPECT THIS
WINTER TO BE LIKE IN THE U.S.?
>> YOU KNOW, ANDERSON, EVERY
MORNING WHEN I GET UP, I TRY TO
SCRAPE THE 5 INCHES OF MUD OFF
MY CRYSTAL BALL AND BE ABLE TO
PREDICT THAT.
AND, YOU KNOW, SO FAR, WE HAVE
DONE A PRETTY GOOD JOB OF
PREDICTING WHERE THIS WOULD BE.
I THINK THE BATTLE BETWEEN
OMICRON AND DELTA IS GOING TO BE
A KEY ONE.
IF, IN FACT, OMICRON IS NOT AS
SEVERE -- AND I KNOW MANY PEOPLE
DON'T WANT TO HEAR THAT BECAUSE
THEY ARE AFRAID THAT WILL GIVE
PEOPLE COMPLACENCY -- BUT I
THINK THE DATA, SO FAR, SHOWS
IT'S NOT AS SEVERE.
BUT IF YOU HAVE IT OFFSET BY
MANY, MANY MORE PEOPLE GETTING
INFECTED THAN WE WOULD WITH
DELTA, THEN YOU MIGHT STILL HAVE
THE SAME IMPACT ON THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
AND RIGHT NOW, WE ARE WATCHING
DELTA EXPLODE IN THIS COUNTRY,
PARTICULARLY IN THE EAST AND THE
SOUTHERN STATES RIGHT NOW ARE
STARTING TO SEE SOME INCREASE.
AND SO, I THINK THAT IF DELTA
WINS OUT, THEN IN FACT WE ARE
GOING TO SEE A MAJOR INCREASE IN
SEVERE ILLNESS.
IF OMICRON WINS OUT, WE MAY SEE
AN INCREASE IN SEVERE ILLNESS
AND WE JUST DON'T KNOW, YET.
>> YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY, LOOK.
A LOT OF PEOPLE LISTENING RIGHT
NOW AT HOME ARE PROBABLY JUST
KIND OF DESPAIRING BECAUSE IT
JUST SEEMS LIKE WE ARE GOING
BACKWARDS.
ONE STEP FORWARD, AND THEN WE GO
DOES THIS JUST GO ON AND ON LIKE
THIS FOR YEARS?
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, SOME PEOPLE
HAD SUGGESTED, WELL, ULTIMATELY,
THE VIRUS WILL KIND OF WEAKEN.
AND IT'S -- ITS ABILITY TO
SPREAD WILL WEAKEN AND THAT'S
WHEN, YOU KNOW, AND MORE PEOPLE
WILL BE VACCINATED AND THAT'S
WHEN WE SORT OF EMERGE INTO A
NEW NORMAL.
>> WELL, ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
WE HAVE RIGHT NOW IS WE DON'T
REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT IT TAKES
TO BE IMMUNE AS A HUMAN.
WE KNOW THAT THE VACCINES WE
HAVE ARE REMARKABLE TOOLS BUT WE
ARE ALSO REALIZING THEY MAY ONLY
PROVIDE LIMITED LONG-TERM
PROTECTION.
AND SO, UNTIL WE CAN GET
POTENTIALLY A BETTER IDE
UNDERSTANDING OF THAT, THE WE
WILL COME UP DO WE NEED NEW
BOOSTERS SIX MONTHS FROM NOW?
WE DON'T KNOW AND WE HAVE TO BE
HONEST WITH THE PUBLIC AND SAY
THAT.
THIS IS A TIME WHERE SCIENCE IS
LEARNING BY THE DAY AND THEN
TRYING TO TRANSLATE, BY THE
NIGHT, TO THE PUBLIC.
AND SO, IT'S VERY CLEAR WE ARE
IN A CONFUSING SITUATION.
I DON'T THINK IT GOES ON LIKE
THIS FOREVER.
BUT IT -- FOR THE -- THIS
IMMEDIATE PERIOD, IT'S NOT CLEAR
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN OVER THE
NEXT FEW MONTHS.
WE CAN SEE NO MATTER WHAT
HAPPENS, THOUGH, YOU ARE GOING
TO BE BETTER OFF IF YOU ARE
FULLY VACCINATED.
FIRST TIMES AND TO GET YOUR
BOOSTER DOSE.
YOU WILL BE BETTER OFF.
>> AND WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
PFIZER'S NEW PILL TO TREAT
COVID?
>> I THINK IT COULD BE A REAL
GAME CHANGER.
I THINK IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
DEVELOPMENT.
MY CONCERN IS EXACTLY WHAT I
HAVE SAID FOR THE LAST YEAR
AROUND VACCINES.
YOU KNOW, I HAVE BEEN SAYING
THERE IS THE LAST MILE AND THE
LAST INCH.
THE LAST MILE'S GETTING THE
VACCINES TO THE PEOPLE.
THE LAST INCH IS GETTING THE
NEEDLE IN THE ARM.
WE HAVE SEEN THAT 40% OF THE
U.S. POPULATION WON'T TAKE THAT
NEEDLE.
WE'RE ALREADY HEARING FEEDBACK
FROM THE STREET THAT SOME PEOPLE
WERE SAYING, WELL, THAT NEW DRUG
IS JUST PART OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
A BIDEN POISON BILL.
WE ARE GOING TO STICK WITH OUR
IVERMECTIN AND NOT GET THE DRUG.
THESE WOULD BE THE SAME PEOPLE
THAT HAVE NOT